alors voilà on a attendu encore une fois
stephen harper répondre sur le thème du
procès de mike de fils à lui colle
dessus on sait depuis quelques semaines
alors bonjour à tous nos ex fédéraux qui
sont avec nous bonjour je suis avec vous
monsieur blackburn parce que évidemment
ça colle toujours à monsieur harper
qu'ils faisaient là qu'il ne peut pas
suivre à la trace lui deux fils ait fait
confiance aux gens qui l'entourent bien
entendu à son équipe mais l'a écoutée
avec ce qu'on a entendu cette semaine le
témoignage de benjamines perrine qui
venu dire le devant les voca puis le
tout le monde puis longtemps que oui
novak était au courant pour le fameux
versement de sa la poste de monsieur
wright à un mic deux filles le seul
témoignage qui est probant ici c'est
lourd comment est ce que stephen harper
peut dire qu'il fait confiance à toute
son équipe alors que là il travaille
avec lui novak les jo c'est son nom
brille novak c'est son nom de confiance
sexuellement bien sûr toute cette
question de la sphère d'office et ce qui
a pris préséance pendant la campagne
électorale depuis le début au point
d'orgue en quelque sorte de mettre le
programme du premier ministre stephen
harper en second plan mais quand même
monsieur a peur toujours garder le cap à
savoir de deux personnes qui étaient qui
devaient rendre des comptes à ce propos
la qui est un mister hype et monsieur
d'ofi alors dans ce contexte là j'ai
l'impression que même si monsieur apport
est un bon entraîneur si on peut dire il
faut reconnaître que c'est au cours des
derniers jours c'est un peu plus
difficile de pouvoir mettre à
l'avant-plan c'est quoi ces programmes
d'autant plus que malgré les belles
annonces que ce soit au niveau 2 du
crédit d'impôt à la rénovation que ce
soit le crédit qu'on va accorder pour
les personnes qui veulent adopter les
enfants ou d'autres nouvelles mesures
comme les réservistes qu'on va croiser
bien c'est comme tomber mais ces
économies en même temps vous comprenez
pourquoi c'est tombé quand c'est rendu
ni si quelqu'un qui était un conseiller
juridique qui s'en vont dire en plein
procès écouter l'homme de confiance
numéro 1 de stephen harper qui s'appelle
ray novak lui il était au courant de
l'ensemble du stratagème il savait que
cet argent là ça venait de la poche de
nigel wright je dis vous avez beau dire
qu'en ce moment ça évacue le programme
vous avez tout à fait raison mais il
reste que là dessus ça dit un petit peu
insoutenable pour stephen harper de
rester si proche de hrinova qui a pas de
tentation plus en plus forte de s'en
départir de créer une grande grande
distance le premier ministre dit qu'il
n'était pas au courant lorsque monsieur
wright a décidé de rembourser les 90
dollars la place de monsieur profit de
promener son garder le cap sur cette
déclaration et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on voit d'ailleurs que celui qui est à
la barre mentionné que il n'était pas au
courant de tous qu'il ya des choses qui
dont il n'avait pas été impliqué en
quelque sorte dans les discussions alors
pour moi j'ai l'impression est même
aujourd'hui on voit que la sphère d'ofi
commencent à s'estomper il reste une
semaine avant que ce procès soit
ajournée pour reprendre en novembre et
l'homme de monsieur harper j'ai bien
l'impression qu'il va tomber en deuxième
vitesse qu'est ce qui vous fait dire que
les taux de fuite en train de s'estomper
parce que liliane aux témoins qui s'en
vient la semaine prochaine à ses jours
début il se devait marquer aujourd'hui
ce n'était plus la première nouvelle ça
commence déjà à diminuer et aussi j'ai
bien l'impression que le ce qui s'est
passé au niveau syndical aujourd'hui le
fait que le syndicat uni fort vient
appuyer le npd il ya beaucoup de
questions que les gens vont devoir poser
à monsieur marqueur c'est quoi qu'il ya
derrière sa caisse qui valeur accrue
accordée dis-je en regard de l'appui
qu'ils leur donnent
qu'est ce que cela implique pour les
contribuables ce qui va vouloir leur
accorder foi il devra le dire je remets
devrait entendre aussi nos autres
participants justement sur le thème
l'arbre restons d'abord sur le thème on
va aborder les autres prêts sur le thème
du procès de mac de file dans les
révélations de cette semaine je vous
donne la parole qui veulent apprendre
qu'il veut réagir en premier oui même
drôle et hérésie oui quand j'ai dit que
uni fort prend la porte du npd il faut
50 attendu ni fort il dit qu'il va faire
un vote stratégique qui veut se
débarrasser de stephen harper c'est ça
qui ont dit c'est surtout qu que
j'écoutais les nouvelles aujourd'hui
quand on regarde l'histoire du procès de
monsieur d'ofi dans ses ports en train
et time
le jogging ferrone c'est une personne
respectable gardien à pardon ça y'a rien
gagné tandis que ray novak à quoi à part
à perdre vraiment puis que déjà c'est la
même personne imaginez vous le fait que
les canadiens et les québécois et
québécoises canadiennes canadienne qui
regarde ça lui dit c'est la personne que
monsieur harper a pris pour récent nomme
de commandes de
confit il travaillait il travaillait
pour
john wayne qui rouvrait pas si email moi
j'ai jamais eu ça l'homme a fait 18 ans
champ politique puis moi je peux vous
dire que nos employés et rouvrent leurs
emails ou qui travaillent pas pour nous
autres madame cops mais je pense que
monsieur monsieur
l'avocat a aussi
renoncé parce que le premier ministre
lui même eu des propos en chambre au
début l'aï dit que la seule personne qui
faisaient ça et qui connaissait ça c'est
anna joe wright depuis le début du
procès on sait qu'il y en a beaucoup
plus et maintenant on sait que le plus
proche de stephen rapp lui qui demeurait
dans sa maison quand il était dans
l'opposition était au courant jusqu'au
point où même son chef de communication
disait que 6
600 600 proches le savaient le premier
ministre le savait on sait pertinemment
qu'il y avait des courriels blackberry
entre nom est john wright est
le nouveau chef du cabinet de trois
semaines avant le procédé mais ça je
n'ai jamais pu voir d'ailleurs ils ont
dit que ça c'est facile à six essais
face mais pas sur le serveur puis je
pense que le parti libéral a écrit une
lettre comme quoi que on pourrait le
sortir par le serveur parce que
normalement ça existe les techniciens y
aurait dit quelque part oui oui oui on
va entendre monsieur paquet aussi mais
moi je pense que le plus dommageable
pour monsieur harper sûrement eu lieu
mais à moins qu'on apprend formellement
qu'il était au courant moi
personnellement je suis convaincu qu'il
était au courant le connaissant et
sachant quel point il veut tout
contrôler et on a vu dans un témoignage
de témoignages de la voix qu'au conseil
quand il ya monsieur harper lui a
demandé son avis concernant mac de fille
le fait qu'il habitait ottawa et qu'il
était sénateur de l'île du prince
édouard monsieur période l'eau dit qu'il
fallait non seulement posséder une
propriété dans l'île du prince édouard
mais il demeure y est le premier
ministre a fait fi de son conseil
d'ailleurs celle là beaucoup frustré on
a pu voir au procès la fondamentale mans
monsieur harper a menti à la population
et je pense que c'est ça qui doit être
sanctionné maintenant c'est vrai que
pour les stratèges conservateurs et on
vient d'entendre jean pierre là dessus
deux modes campagne encore peut se
passer bien des choses mais pour le
moment en tout cas ça fait beaucoup plus
de dommages que je pense ce que les
stratèges conservateurs peut imaginer
mais là maintenant c'est peut-être les
circonstances la semaine difficile sur
le plan économique on a eu qui va
permettre justement à monsieur harper de
changer de thème les thèmes que vous
souhaitez que voir aborder d'ailleurs
monsieur blackburn on peut écouter
justement ce que monsieur rapport a dit
pas plus tard que ce après midi
c'est certainement pas le temps pour des
stratégies un risque est proposée par le
npd de moqueur et les libéraux de trous
d'eau ça c'est une grande augmentation
des dizaines de milliards $ de nouvelles
dépenses financées par des hausses de
taxes et d'impôts et des défis
permanents sas c'est ces deux moments
moment très dangereux dans la vie de
notre pays notre économie pour une
stratégie m6 risques et c'est pour cette
raison c'est nécessaire de maintenir le
cap de notre plan conservateur
alors voilà on voit les marchés qui
s'effondrent comme jamais hier ça s'est
répété aujourd'hui pires semaines on
n'avait jamais vu quelque chose comme ça
ce qui permet justement monsieur
blackburn à stephen harper de ramener le
thème de l'économie mais surtout de
pouvoir à son tour lancé on pourrait
dire des des missiles sur ses
adversaires justement sur ce thème là
parce que si vous avez deux parties ici
qui se proposent pour prendre ma place
mais qui eux vont s'engager dans de
grandes dépenses alors que si vous vous
fiez sur moi le bateau va aller à bompas
ça doit réjouir les conservateurs
d'entendre maintenant ce thème là qui
est en train tranquillement de reprendre
une place mais comme vous savez monsieur
harper est extrêmement rigoureux la
question ne pas augmenter les impôts
puis de pas augmenter les taxes est
quelque chose d'important pour lui veut
faire en sorte d'arriver à ce qu'on
puisse réduire la dette du canada et
maintenant on a un budget équilibré et
là vous voyez justement cette
association entre les syndicats et le
npd d'où les questions qui vont venir
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière ce qu'est ce
que monsieur marqueur s'est engagé à
donner aux syndicats en pour obtenir
leur appui est ce que ça veut dire qu'à
la prochaine convention collective
il va leur accorder toutes les hausses
de salaires qu'ils veulent il va leur
accorder de nouveaux bénéfices marginaux
il va tout enlever les boîtes postales
qui sont que deux tiers des canadiens
ont déjà leur courrier par boîte postale
pour recommencer à zéro ça va coûter à
peu près 500 millions s'est réjoui élevé
revenir l'argent oui d'où va venir leur
jeu mais et c est ce que je peux juste
faire appeler un jean-pierre parce qu'il
est tenant dans la période de monsieur
moroni moi aussi le seul gouvernement
qui a mené 7
budget équilibré de suite c'est le parti
libéral avec jean chrétien et paul
martin depuis l'arrivée des
conservateurs il n'y a pas eu de budget
à équilibrer et si monsieur j'ai un peu
veut prétendre que celui qui va combler
les déficits comment ça se fait qu'il a
fait cette difficile de suite et il est
tendre que c'est lui le gérant de
l'économie alors que c'est nous les
libéraux qui ont mis les choses en ordre
avec avec l'équipe chrétien martin
pendant dix ans
je m'entends se souvenait aussi là
dessus parce que ça fait deux fois le
monsieur blackburn à ceux ci fortement
dans son message
npd et syndicats et les deux fois plutôt
qu'une alors quand vous entendez ça vaut
rien je sais comment regarder si
monsieur harper qui a donné qu'à laon 2
milliards de baisses d'impôts grosses
corporations ont même temps les grosses
réparations prendre les banques pour un
exemple fait vesle 2 milliards de
profits ce sans payer ans milliards de
bonus que tu sais monsieur harper a fait
de lui il l'a promis dans l'économie
avec les gens de chez nous la bouteille
d'économies dans alès ça va pas si bien
que ça il a dépensé avec des pétrolières
puis les bains un puissant gang madame
club vient nous dire que les libéraux a
balancé le budget c'est promis il l'a
fait sur le dos des travailleurs en
valant 50 7 milliards à la caisse
d'assurance emploi à chaque fois il y
avait un surplus dans les budgets des
libéraux puis monsieur paul martin il y
avait sept milliards de surplus à la
caisse d'assurance ans pour que les
travailleurs et les employeurs avaient
payé dedans puis c'est 100 kg et il
faisait partie des francs je leur aurais
je pense pour les verts qui est un point
qu'au québec la viande mais manière
procès vivant le problème si vous avez
volé la caisse le candidat du monde qui
avait pas de plus madame corps mais le
problème ils vont vous avez jamais formé
un gouvernement national ce soir la tête
de vos confrères ici là ça change
constants voire le faire puisque ou
enfin parce que les aime et les rosaces
toujours été les premiers à balancer le
budget je voulais sauver dans ton droit
mais vous savez aussi votre dit ministre
des finances celui qui était annoncé par
votre chalet toronto c'est ce qu'il a
fait de la première chose qu'il a faite
quand il est entré dans le grand sud
catch your death et qui a b c d impôt
coopération venez je venais je n'ai pas
une grosse
dénoncées contre cette baisse de talent
dire à 11 % à 9 % obtient des moyens
dans du bris qui crée 80 % des emplois
au canada non mais c'est votre votre
votre diplôme de finance à fait la même
chose qu'à bordeaux n'était aussi
monsieur paquet qu'on n'a pas entendu
beaucoup
sur un peu je pense pas que le thème de
l'économie soit vraiment gagnant pour
lui parce que quand même des difficultés
qu'on connaît présentement viennent du
choix de la politique industrielle
conservatrice c'est à dire tout misé sur
le pétrole l'automobile on l'a vu
pendant la grande crise la grande
dépression le gouvernement a aidé et
surtout ces deux la grande récession le
gouvernement aidé surtout ces deux
secteurs là et dès qu'il ya eu des
surplus envisagé il les a dilapidé par
des pour des fins électorales le
fractionnement du revenu par exemple
pour les personnes les plus riches la
prestation fiscale pour enfants qui a
été augmenté l'été dernier et cette
façon d'agir le visées strictement
empêcher les partis d'opposition d'avoir
la marge de manoeuvre nécessaire pour
respecter leurs engagements alors il ya
créé un problème non seulement pour au
parti conservateur mieux créer un
problème aussi au npd aux libéraux qui
ont extrêmement des difficultés à
respecter leurs engagements et je veux
terminer en disant dieu tous ces partis
là veulent maintenir la même stratégie
en faveur du pétrole et de l'automobile
que ce soit les conservateurs le npd ou
les libéraux alors que le bloc québécois
remet en question justement est le seul
parmi leurs maîtres en clair que l'on
sait la fois énergie s est maintenant
belledune monsieur paquette a longtemps
justement du bloc québécois alors vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir qui a eu un
sondage cette semaine qui montrent que
le parti néo démocrates étant grand
grande avance ici dans le territoire de
la province du québec alors une avance
pour michel serrault gizeh sondage d'été
ça vaut ce que ça vaut c'est vrai qu'on
est en début de campagne pires encore
deux mois faire bien entendu mais ça
quand même forcé monsieur duceppe à
boire la réaction que voici
il arrive qu'on pénale face aux vingt et
une fois qu'on a pédalé pinceau 1
restant de la route on a le vent dans le
dos on avait le vent dans le dos au
départ on avait le camp d'en face à la
fin alors on va travailler très fort
pour que ça soit les inverse
bon alors monsieur paquet manifestement
monsieur tu sais votre très très en
forme à la fin de cette campagne j'ai
fait beaucoup de vélo il était à perdre
un gain en termes de santé mais est-ce
qui va terminer la campagne aussi avec
des gains du côté électorale le pays
reste deux semaines le dernier sondage
était très différent du sondage qu'on
avait vu dans le devoir le léger
marketing qui donnait 21% par exemple on
bloque à égalité avec le parti libéral
évidemment je pense que personne veut
nier le fait que le npd au québec
actuellement est en avance mais on est à
deux mois des élections est l'objectif
du blog c'est de ramasser un vote qui
est à la fois le vote des souverainistes
parce que tout à fait logique comptable
pour le blog de justice
me reste deux mois pour convaincre une
bonne partie de la population québécoise
que le vote stratégique c'est de voter
pour le bloc québécois d'envoyer des
gens non seulement qu'ils défendent
l'option souverainiste mais qui défend
aussi le québec sans compromis mais je
suis tout à fait d'accord que cette
démonstration n'a pas été encore faite
de façon suffisante et que beaucoup de
souverainistes france par exemple qu'en
votant pour le npd on va se débarrasser
du gouvernement conservateur mon se
débarrasse repos d'un gouvernement de
partis fédéralistes alors c'est pour ça
que dans le fond c'est un mauvais choix
stratégiques mais je le comprends très
bien c'est le même choix qu'en 2011 qui
a amené à l'élection d'un gouvernement
majoritaire conservateur alors donc il
reste deux mois moi je pense que
monsieur mulcair va avoir beaucoup de
difficulté à maintenir sa stratégie
actuelle où il parle où je le
mentionnais la première la première
semaine un peu des deux côtés de la
bouche quand il parle ça va être
difficile et on l'a vu entre autres
quand justin trudeau l'emmener sur la
question de la loi sur la clarté ou là
il a réitéré la position du npd sur les
allemands justement le volet du npd
j'aimerais qu'on termine avec ce bloc
l'homme a quel sens va s'adresser
d'abord et c'est à monsieur gaudin
monsieur mulcair a surpris bien des gens
quand il a abordé le thème de la
sécurité renforcer la présence policière
dans les villes tchèques ou les
observateurs ont dit voyons il est en
train de jouer ici dans le terrain de la
droite alors qu'il est censé être à la
tête d'un parti de gauche alors
monsieur blackburn vous parle tout le
temps de l'union avec les syndicats les
observateurs regardent et ce en envoyant
en train de jouer dans le talent de
droite qu'est ce qui se passe avec le
npd tranquillement les change de
position n'ont absolument pas parce que
si vous regardez le npd moi je vous
donne mon opinion quand vous regardez le
npd c'est pas des prisons qui on veut
bâtir c'est pas des instructions pour
mettre le monde derrière les barreaux
ces polices de surveillance mais plus de
100 voyance sur le terrain vous savez
donc une ville il ya beaucoup de
surveillants j'ai beaucoup de policiers
alan tôt les gens chez nous quand qui
nous disent exemple dans nos villes nos
villages quand les policiers sont
présents il ya moins de choses qui se
passent alors c'est ça qui dit c'est ça
c'est ça que jack layton disait aussi en
même temps faut renforcir notre force
policière et non bâtir des prises à deux
battants qui est immense de faire je
veux dire écoutez moi je me sens la
manière que monsieur pierre paquette par
lui parle chez nous autant à la doua
depuis monsieur blackburn dit quant à la
gauche vous êtes tout de même que jusque
s'agrandissent et qu' on est dans un
parti que cheikh ça fait mal aux autres
participants ça paraît bien qu une
possibilité qu'on devient finalement
gouvernements au canada après cinq ans
en 60 ans d'existence on a eu les
libéraux et les conservateurs l'aube ou
150 un wiki liaison sans écueil repeat
année qui veulent garder pour quelque
chose
et nous restent seconds ils ne restent
pas c'est bon c'est monsieur paquet très
finement puis matin je n'ai jamais vu
que le npd est un parti de droite jeudi
que la stratégie économique jeunes pdc
la même que les conservateurs
le dernier mois madame messieurs michael
est mort de thatcher il a travaillé pour
le jeu vidéo les sectes me suis donné là
il est né dans le
président fusent et moi ce qui veut dire
monsieur marc app être qu'est ce que
vous voulez qu'ils soient moins mais
certainement pas de haine npd de sushis
vous aussi la chine monsieur trudeau sur
la chine n'en voit la bcc sur ce mot là
mon mandat sera voté au cerveau